Pamela headline is on her way in I'm
excited to talk to Pamela yeah tell her
to stop that guy up in the hallway
Ali get up stop talking to her bringing
some guy with torn-up jeans I guys got
nothing going on nothing I got yeah who
was he who was Sam how are you hello
welcome good to see him welcome Pamela
add lon
mmm you smell good thank you hi how are
you
we're on are you I'm seeing no I'm Sam
hi and that's Jim you know Jim I know
Jim yes you do yes you do they're
hugging and kissing and embracing he
doesn't very much I was a tinkle
reference he knows good good hi that's
Travis Travis he's getting fired and
that's uh yeah I love it I've been fired
a lot have you oh god yes from wine um
lots of things yeah lots of TV shows and
stuff what did you get what was the
first time you get five Marty show um it
was probably the red fox show yeah you
got did you tonight I got replaced by
Sinbad did you yeah
you can't probably feel too bad about
yourself you're like maybe they were
going for something yeah got it
but Jimmy she um she handed me a little
something and I opened it up I like boys
to do boy things with the bottle of
water on so what you the red fox sure
how old were you need it you were very
young right I was like 18 and did you
how did you get that gig auditioned in
drag as Paul Segal because my other name
Segal um never she changed me name a big
mistake
um but yeah like they were they wanted a
boy to be Reds like he was fostering
somebody and so um all these uh these
these boys audition to be that boy and
then I had just done a movie that I
played a girl who turns into a boy like
I grew a dick
I threw like a crystal
at the moon Seth Green sells me a
crystal because he's like a little junk
man and he says uh you know at the total
eclipse of the moon you throw this
crystal and think about your deepest
darkest heart's desire and I wake up the
next day and I got a dick what movie was
this it's called um something special or
Willy Mille or I was a teenage boy it
had three names Wow Wow yeah so this
should get a lot more credit cuz this
was way before trans was like a sale and
they should sell those crystals you
asked about oh you're gonna write but
then I got fired from down the shore
because I didn't you know I wasn't like
really sexy or sexy enough and then you
know yeah that's something special well
when you got fired for a red fox show
how long did you do the show for I did a
bunch of them um uh I guess I don't know
I did like six or something like that
and and boy this was the 80s there was a
lot going on there it was a little bit
crazy but yeah I was still sad you know
how they tell you they brought me into
the office and they were like we kinda
can't have you on anymore because it was
like you know to be honest like they
were there was like a thing about me
being a little white girl and red being
this like old black guy and they were
like afraid of like intimate spaces and
things like that and so I was like you
know I felt like an old black guy inside
so I thought we belong together
right but um I think that that was kind
of an issue you know honestly what was
he like he's a guy he was amazing what
he was my buddy he's nice to you oh I
loved him I loved him a lot
I'll tell you more stories when we're
not I'm Mike was the first when's the
first time you met him was it was it
during the audition or when you get
after you got the gig
it was I auditioned and I had um I had
bound my tits and I was I full I mean
I looked like a dude I mean looking at
you in the right yeah my god and yeah I
was just like I was just like a little
dude so you know everybody thought I was
a dude and he was like Ally's new I was
new and he was just he was the best
so how did they find out well there's
nothing girl did you hand somebody a
thing and ask them to open it no I would
never had the time they find out ever um
after each thing there would always be
somebody like the casting woman Barbara
Miller knew and like I would go in to
meet red and or I'd meet the the
producers and then I would leave and
they would say Pamela and I would be
like don't tell them I'm Pamela we just
told them so I would walk back in the
room and I just opened my shirt and I
have an ace bandage on my chest and they
would be like oh my god oh my god that's
amazing
that's the red four we looking at we're
looking at the UH looks like a newspaper
and it's crazy the Redbox show oh my god
that's a Barry Van Dyke that's Dick Van
Dyke son on the right the handsome dude
yeah and that's you right there the
small yeah and there's red I'm a dude
yeah I am a dude you just wanted parts
so bad at that point that it would be
like whatever if I can if I did want
parts um I you know I I just was very
comfortable in the gender bendy place I
always like identified very like in a
masculine way um it doesn't matter
people's perception of me because people
are always like you're you're so girly
you're such a girl but I've always been
a just I'm comfortable in that world so
that was all great for me right and it
it's funny because like a couple years
ago I realized I started out doing this
like crossover thing on camera and on
stage and then I ended up getting famous
for in animation
and Bobby is bothered yeah right right
what the boy voice you did you remember
when you I mean I know you're 18 but do
you remember the voice you did when I
was like this I was like mr. Hughes
misty
hey mr. Hughes what's up oh that guy was
robbing the newsstand and I wanted to
you know a little bit different than
that guy Bobby Hill from Arlen Texas but
yeah you know just like kind of my like
you know um I'm a boy you know thing I
don't know did you teach yourself to do
voices because you weren't an orc in
show business badly and it's like this
is a tool or just you just did them yeah
I just I just didn't know I mean I I
grew up like just consuming cartoons and
you know like all of the like Bugs Bunny
and and wacky races and all of that
stuff but I never was like I'm gonna get
this voice down or anything like that I
didn't have an aspiration to do that I
just wanted to work I just wanted to be
in the business so did you audition like
we got something like okay I want to do
a cartoon voice or you just happen to do
it you heard an audition like I'll try
this um you mean like for Bobby oh it
was an audition it was just like they
just handed me the sides and they said
okay he's a little 12 year old boy from
Texas and I was like oh [ __ ] I wish I
watch badlands last night or something
right me you know what I mean and um and
you know and just from then on and for
that audition one of them Greg Daniels
was in a room and he had a bunch of
sketches on a quark board and he said I
hope you don't think I'm rude I'm going
to turn away from you and I'm going to
look at the sketch as as you do this and
I said no it's no problem and and then I
went and I did I voice to the animatic
which is like the pencil sketch and and
then I got it I didn't know that I was
stepping into what would be like the
holy grail of you know a situation in
life yeah because that ran for 13
seasons and I think it's [ __ ]
brilliant I learned
so much about writing now my own show
and working on Louie from being a voice
actor on king of the hill because those
those scripts were so brilliant how how
I want to take you to voice one episode
for me no time but for them to animate
at nine months one Episode yeah Wow yeah
because that was when it was like not
all on computers yeah and whatever so we
would just go in and have a recording
one day and we'd be done in like six
hours four hours whatever only you know
with like [ __ ] around and going to
the green room and everything like that
and then the animation process to nine
months oh did you work with my judge or
was he how is he yeah he's the best
is he amazing oh yeah you would love him
he's just I've interviewed him on the
phone but never met him he's yeah he's
really he's a brilliant sweet thoughtful
guy as as his Greg Daniels you know
what's he like creatively like is he is
he telling you like this is this is what
it needs to sound like is he like here's
the script like just kind of do stuff
with it they they really got to a place
where they were they were trusting the
actors like we were our own Bible for
the characters and like at a certain
point like season you know nine I said
can I not say fruit pie or prop comic
for one year
can we just you know I can put a stop to
that why would you say fruit pilot
because because Bobby loved fruit pies
yeah and he wanted to be a prop comic
and so you know but they went into so
many different areas and I just I I
learned so much from Mike and Greg and
those writers it's amazing yeah and your
show now Sam has seen the three I have
not I didn't know we had a link to it
I'm a terrible person
he says better things on ten ten o'clock
on FX
on Thursdays it's a good show and and
you created it with Louis right yeah how
is it also you know what we're talking
about
I created it with my life but how is it
doing a series like Louise got into this
place I feel like we're
he gets to so be like God yeah exactly
he gets that he gets to Jason Moses so
then what's he like to work with on
something that's so yours cuz this is
very this is yours and your life and the
whole thing oh you know he's he was it I
mean he's the perfect person because
we've known each other for 11 years
right
Jimmy and he and I did lucky Louie and
we should tell a story about how I
rummage to get your sweater and no I
told I still have that I haven't I
haven't Pam sent me the the rich sweater
from lucky Louie
now this disgusting you don't understand
like oh we we okay Rick Shapiro uh-huh
and Jim Norton and I like all of a
sudden they waited nine months the
amount of time it takes to gestate a
baby and create one episode of king of
the hill they waited that amount of time
to tell us
we weren't picked up that's right lucky
Louie I remember walking with Louie on
like 6th Avenue at him going we still
don't we still one more shot they see it
talked to Robert woohoo it said it took
them a long time to find out when they
were doing so you would call each other
Jim would call me ago hey what do you
think what do you think you think we're
gonna get picked up and I'm like oh [ __ ]
I think so I don't think so I don't know
and then when it got to be like seven
months eight months nine months it would
be kind of rude at this point if they
didn't pick us up right right so then
they didn't [ __ ] pick us up and so I
was like where's all our [ __ ] like you
know Kim and Louie
we had wedding rings on the show I had a
pair of glasses that that like this
optician made for me my that red leather
jacket uh-huh there's this sweater yeah
Jimmy you know Jim wore that dis always
Bing sweater gross brown sweater he seen
but one of every evidently showed every
seen my god who's finding these is that
that's killing me
yeah and um also didn't you wear a thing
on your foot like an orthopedic oh I got
I that was for real I heard
for real that was a legit that wasn't a
character choice that was Jim Norton
stepped into a whole walking process
because you have foot thing on your foot
foot thing on my foot that's right that
was back then but I went oh I still have
that mc5 shirt but um I went into the
storage space because they said we just
threw it into storage and now it's like
in general population I'm like Jesus
this [ __ ] should be in the Smithsonian
Institution you loved that show I loved
I loved that show yeah but I predicted
it predicted I said this show is amazing
you know they always they said that we
put canned laughs in never they had to
turn it down
people went [ __ ] crazy in the studio
and I remember you said it's like it's
like they took a crack house they they
emptied it out into a bus and they
brought everybody here sometimes we
would have the craziest audiences and
they'd be talking to us they were as you
were shooting out no you did it no she
did it and none of them were on
characters cuz the episodes had never
air of course they were all learning
about all of us in the in that moment
and they still respond telling you it
was like the the you know those old they
would do like Barn Theatre with like
Mickey Rooney and like all of that it
felt like that and as somebody who's
been acting since you're a little kid
are you sitting around going like this
doesn't happen guys it was I'm telling
you it's still I love talking about it
because it was such a singular time we
did two shows on Friday nights that's
right we would tape we did we should
tape Thursday and Friday and then they
condensed it to that's right or we did
two shows in a row it was it was nuts
yeah we were we we started on Monday we
were off-book on our feet taping on
Thursdays and it was just electric it
was electric so laughs in that studio
you know that I remember one guy
criticized that a canned laughter the
laughter is too loud and I'm like there
was Louis wood called he keeps playing
the whole sweetening process of laughter
yeah and how they sweeten it on every
sitcom you've ever seen and he wouldn't
permit it he would not allow them to
sweeten the laughs oh no
so the Jovan would have to turn it down
because you couldn't hear and
everybody's like that's so [ __ ] fake
and it was 90 percent awesome so what
was it that you predicted I knew that it
was going to be something and be
meaningful I knew it was going to make a
mark but it would be like a blip on the
radar I knew we were too soon
that's what I was going to say because
it's one of those shows that like what's
unfair about it and somebody who wasn't
on it but just watched it like when you
put the DVDs in now and just watch it
back you're like holy [ __ ] like what why
wouldn't this show have gotten picked up
by try to shelve it like we a lot of
viewers and a lot of viewers and the
critics didn't like it and it's so funny
how the people like Louis success now he
got murdered for this shot I remember
[ __ ] killed for porn it hurt it hurt
him they really he was broke after the
show like they really [ __ ] beat up
Louie they were not hard feelings yeah
they were nasty yeah Pootie Tang was
really tough on him and then this like
he had just been and he had just done it
a pilot before that st. Louis or
something like that but I mean you know
he really really tried and he I mean
this is all his vision when we did the
camera test the director on the show was
like please tell me you're not going to
shoot it on video please tell me or not
and he was like I want to shoot it on
video like that show looks like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and it looks crazy and it's not
right and they're not doing it right but
I mean and why did he want to shoot it
on video he wanted it to feel like a
Norman Lear show right back from that
time when he was growing up and he had a
long conversation with Norman Lear who's
one of his idols and Norman Lear said
you don't think that I had the option of
film of course I could have filmed my
shows but he chose to shoot his shows on
video and so it was like a warm
comforting thing so when Louis starts
doing well and like Louie becomes like
the critics darling mm-hmm are you like
at home going like I where were you guys
before
you know it's just it you know things
come you know there's a time for
everything you know I I'm I was a new
mom newer mom when I met Jimmy and
they're my youngest was not even two
years old and um you know it's just
there's there's periods there's there's
gestation Xand you just gotta wait for
things to cook and so it's just all part
of the growing and learning process and
so this put him where he is now right
because he was allowed to fail in some
respects and succeed because to me this
show was a huge success
yeah do you see any of the people I have
not seen I bumped into uh Jerry uh minor
me too it Walter was very funny deadpan
I've not seen Kelly GUI I thought was so
cute as a kid and Emma Stone have
actually bumped into a few times yeah
and she had a really nice experience
playing the girl who offered Lily a blow
job that's right uncle C do you wait did
you say the line look at the [ __ ] that
came out of that [ __ ] [ __ ] or was that
Mike Haggerty might well Mike Haggerty
played her dad so I don't diddy I don't
know or did Louise say that one of you
guys I don't know II I don't remember
saying that but gotta see I don't know
now that's a different one that's God as
a [ __ ] that's a different that's a
different one that we got they have all
of these that was a different one that's
amazing
we're just looking at these YouTube they
have this screen I'm um mesmerizing it
what was it like what was it like for
you being there with like being in that
because you had Rick and Louie and Jim
like all together it's this like you
know and Jerry minor yeah hanging out
with the but hanging out with the
comedians specifically like what did you
how did you and Laura Kiely we were
titling her the comedians were the ones
paranoid we were eating a fire every
week long we got to every week I'm like
I'm done
I [ __ ] I hated the HBO run-throughs
would happen on Wednesday Carolyn
Strauss and all them would come
and they would never let I [ __ ]
bombed at every HBO night run-through
it's not true I'm sorry because you're a
comedian so you came into the cold world
of television and they're all just
sitting there listening and watching so
the only person who's laughing was Mike
Royce because he's going on Oh and so
you know people don't react and it's
just like I'm so used to that but you
guys weren't you need something coming
back for you
yeah that's why the live tapings were
always they they went really well and it
was always fun and like we would have to
do another take and Louie go what else
you got for that like with all because
as a comic he didn't like doing the same
thing twice yeah if he could have
avoided Mike Haggerty was a funny
[ __ ] dude - genius the guy who played
his friend he was really I haven't seen
him since I mean I I should try to keep
up with him - such a nice - sweetheart a
sweetheart you have to be proud of of
your show now though oh I am I can't
even believe it it's like you know how
is it super autobiographical is it like
it you know it is I mean it's it's you
know duh you know it's my my life it's I
I'm a single mom three daughters English
mother lives across the street
check check check right I'm an actor I
do dirty on-camera things I do animation
things and everything but then I'm able
to tell other stories like my you know
stories from my childhood that I can
infuse into my television daughter's and
things like that how does your mom feel
about being portrayed as a good crazy
she's happy to be part of the
conversation pseudo racist did you see
that episode I showed it to her and she
said I know why you put that in there
you know but it's like I mean she never
said that right
a relative of ours did say that one time
and I was like oh this is a nightmare
would they say it's a very fun oh if I
want to spoil the punch spoiler yci
my watch the last episode last week's
episode with Lenny Kravitz on it yeah it
was a good one and I thought I was gonna
say that episode did such a good job of
like tackling the racial thing without
beating you over the head with it you
know yeah well I mean that's the thing
it's like if you get into like a writers
room or a situation like that people are
like why did why did she say that we
need an explanation no that's not good
we've got to make up for it over here
and we need a big payoff over here I
don't have any of that in my show and I
just it's basically it's the way I'm
feeling and looking at things from
inside it's like the cameras inside my
chest right and you guys get to
experience it from Sam's point of view
right yeah it seemed like it seems like
a lot of your dialogue on the show is
probably what you're thinking
in real life yeah not that you're that
like yeah and I also I wanted it to uh I
just wanted everything to feel authentic
and real and I wanted it to be like you
know when I would get my actors I would
say just keep it simple you know what I
mean you don't have to do too much don't
look for a big button big payoff let the
moment lay there like a fart I'm looking
for a lot of farts this is what I want
in my show yeah it's what I want a
relationship do you like being that
creative hands-on or do you like having
the less responsibility of just acting
oh I I prefer the creative owning you
know I was like I had so much [ __ ] to
learn dialog wise you know because we
were cross boarding which means that we
were shooting like five episodes in one
week like pieces of them so I'd be like
where am I going
what just happened you know trying to
piece it all together and I said oh god
if we get picked up for season toy toy
toy which we just did I'm just gonna
react to people thank you that's just
don't want to have any dialogue I just
want people to talk at me and me go home
I don't know man but it's cool to be
able to at least way in on the project
whatever you're shooting something
there's got to be a thing like I wish
they were doing this and not that and
when it's yours they're gonna do this
and they're gonna do what you want oh
it's incredible because I could just go
you know what I don't I don't believe in
this I just changed my mind
come here Luke and I'll take my camera
guy and I say just put the camera over
here and then we could shoot over here
and I want you to say this and I don't
want you to say that and I want you to
say her line here and there's no ego and
there's no preciousness and there's no
[ __ ] focus group yeah all the focus
groups always help Excel you like
they're terrific yeah yeah when I what's
funny yeah have you dealt with them
before yeah I mean the first focus
groups that I've ever dealt with were
when I I was a room parent like in
school and like 15 people are on an
email and it's just like that sounds
great
I'll bring banana pie I think we should
use the money for a vacuum cleaner in
the in the classroom and I just you know
every time I get an email with more than
one person on it I just reply to one
person reply all is a nightmare
yes the same thing in a process when
you're making a show and that's why
working on FX is so great because they
do not focus group you to death and it's
also just to press call better things
and it's on Thursdays at 10:00 o'clock
and by the way if you have the FX at
that's how I watched it if you get the
app on Apple TV or whatever you can
watch all the episodes
oh I mean the three that have aired
that's the whole season but cool it's a
good show I know yeah I would check it
out we're getting out of here oh yes 11
o'clock our [ __ ] done our shows done so
watch better things Thursday at 10:00
p.m. Thank You Pamela at Pamela aztlán
on Twitter I'm so happy to see I wish we
had you longer this is not yeah yeah
very proud of you thank you I love this
yeah it's just fun you throw back her
like if she says I'm so proud you say
thank you say why don't you two now
because she's doing Pam's had her own
show she doesn't she
she's proud of me for talking to you
she'd be nice so you're just taking the
Congress as she's being nice ya know ya
know one person do you have a lovely
person that is lovely
thank you all yeah we'll be back
tomorrow yes we wait hey I'm still on
the thing thank you so much Yeah right
pamela show she's awesome